buonasera a tutti io mi chiamo isabel
bna e vengo dalla scuola popolare di
musica di testaccio sono molto siamo
molto emozionati di essere stati
invitati qui ai the jicks di lecce e
ringraziamo tutta l'organizzazione che
ci ha permesso questa bellissima
occasione insieme alla giovane orchestra
del salento e in realtà vi devo
raccontare tante cose cercherò di essere
o solo tre minuti quindi non è facile e
volevo raccontare la nostra esperienza
intorno alla parola e comunicazione e
integrazione e il nostro lavoro oggi del
coro delle mani bianche vedrete solo due
ragazzi che ci seguono da cinque anni
il nuovo coro delle mani bianche quello
che si è formato quest'anno che formato
da ragazzi sordi e ragazzi disabili non
era pronto per venire perché ci poi ci
vuole tempo per conoscersi ci vuole
tempo per segnare insieme e giulia e
francesco invece hanno già fatto
numerosi concerti altri che segnavano
intorno insieme a loro hanno deciso di
prendere un'altra strada e giu allora se
vogliamo raccontare le particolarità
perché in questo coro si iscrivono anche
persone normodotate
e come giulia per esempio che
assolutamente normodotato ma anche lei
ha una storia particolare perché nasce
con un problema di cardiopatia e invece
francesco con una sindrome chiamata di
gs quindi di autismo ad alto
funzionamento ha una grandissima
sensibilità artistica e quindi è molto
felice di partecipare a questo progetto
da addirittura cinque anni e perché
volevo parlare di queste due parole
perché l'integrazione non è una cosa
così ovvia e spesso la coloriamo un po
in una maniera diciamo con una
connotazione sociale quasi politica come
una forzatura o un bisogno di stare
insieme tutti allo stesso modo ma quando
lavoriamo non è esattamente così per cui
spesso non è vero che il ragazzo sordo è
contento di stare insieme al ragazzo
disabile non è vero che il ragazzo o
meno disabile è contento di stare con
quello più disabile non è vero che il
ragazzo normodotato è contento di
cantare insieme al ragazzo disabile
allora come si raggiunge questa
integrazione questa comunicazione
intanto sicuramente con la sensibilità e
con l'amore ma ci vogliono degli
strumenti uno degli strumenti che
abbiamo nel coro delle mani bianche e la
lingua dei segni la lis lingua italiana
segni ci tengo a dirvi che io non ho i
diplomi della lista noi abbiamo un
interprete che lavora con noi e che ci
diciamo ci dà le tra le sue tradizioni
le confezioni li confezioniamo insieme
però è un lavoro estremamente
emozionante è una lingua che interessa
tutti che interessa e normodotati che
interessa i ragazzi con disabilità i
loro genitori i loro operatori e
naturalmente ragazzi sordi perché il
loro modo di esprimersi
forse perché questa lingua a risveglia è
una lingua spaziale che risveglia in noi
delle memorie antiche e che ci parla ad
un altro livello ma oltre questo come
avviene l'integrazione allora in realtà
è l'incontro in un evento artistico con
un evento artistico veramente le
sensibilità delle persone quindi la
parte a nemica delle persone la loro
anima si incontrano su un terreno che
non è più materiale ma che è un terreno
artistico spirituale e vorrei concludere
con questa bellissima frase del maestro
josé antonio abreu che ha creato le
orchestre i cori nel venezuela che dice
l'animo umano non conosce disabilità
grazie
noi siamo veramente entusiasti di
partecipare a questo evento di farlo col
coro delle mani bianche è un'opportunità
in più per la giovane orchestra per
dimostrare quanto la musica possa
funzionare possa essere il linguaggio
ideale per mettersi in comunicazione
sentir parlare isabelle sentirle dire
quanto il linguaggio dei segni sia una
forma di comunicazione efficiente mi
ricorda molto di come noi
fondamentalmente utilizziamo la musica
per comunicare e per imparare a stare
insieme
la giovane orchestra è un progetto
musicale che coinvolge tantissimi
ragazzi negli ultimi cinque anni sono
forse più di 150 ragazzi che si sono
avvicendati in questo orchestra è
partita con una idea molto semplice quel
fatto che secondo noi il salento
rappresenta un territorio privilegiato
una sorta di di terreno molto fertile
per la musica negli ultimi 20 anni in
questo territorio sono avvicendate delle
esperienze musicali molto importanti che
addirittura hanno fatto diventare forse
un punto di riferimento se così si può
dire su tutto il panorama nazionale ma
la nostra idea iniziale era come i
ragazzi che sono nati meno di venti anni
fa hanno come dire vissuto questa
crescita
la crescita della musica del salento e
come la possono esprimere con questa
idea abbiamo fatto l'audizione cinque
anni fa cercando una trentina di ragazzi
sono presentati in 100 e da quel momento
quello che abbiamo potuto fare di meglio
era accogliere li abbiamo accolti tutti
e con loro abbiamo cominciato a lavorare
e stato difficile all'inizio avevamo
tipo nuove batterie 5 di dare elettrica
e un'orchestra assolutamente fuori dal
comune e proprio utilizzando questa
unicità
il fatto cioè che non ci fosse uno
schema prestabilito
abbiamo sviluppato
tra musica abbiamo chiesto ai ragazzi
che cosa volevano suonare abbiamo
cercato di capire cosa volevano
esprimere con la musica e questo così è
diventato un gruppo in cui ognuno si
sente libero di fare la musica intesa
come mezzo di comunicazione
assolutamente libero come ponte verso
quello che la propria anima appunto
vuole comunicare e questo si è
concretizzato in una serie
devo dire numerosa di brani totalmente
inediti nei testi nelle musiche che noi
abbiamo composto spesso partendo da
piccole idee dei ragazzi che abbiamo
sviluppato insieme e questo gruppo nel
corso degli anni ha imparato a suonare
insieme
ha imparato a vivere insieme a convivere
e soprattutto ha imparato un piccolo
segreto della musica e cioè che prima di
esprimersi bisogna fare silenzio bisogna
saper ascoltare in questo modo è
possibile forze dare la risposta
migliore è la musica ti aiuta perché e
senza filtri cerca la risposta in una
zona inesplorata e a volte proprio
quella zona inesplorata di noi può
offrire
la parola più adatta una parola che ci
connette realmente con l'altro va bene
cominciamo
no
ciao
e di amore
gli occhi
cazzo
il mondo
non c'è
dopo
roma
si no
niente
siamo
jobs
fine della guerra
non bene con su scritto il proprio nome
le cappe pranzo
intorno
animati da aprile in città di bra
il mio professore tema
del pirla
sì
no
che parla
non mi pento
la storia
a
una delle guerre
bene
male
ester
il pazzo
via le guerre
va giù
a prima
tu
albero
appello per le orecchie
lei
adesso le giovani
va beh
si no
lerda
a tanto
nel mio radice fame
ha pertanto
mai
tutti la fame per decidere
ma d'aria
io non mi fermo
aperta
a guardare
a m
mai
no